- [Chantel] Hey.
- Hey.
- Do you just want to stay in tonight?
- Yeah, let's do it!
- Okay, cool.
(victory music)
- Oh.
- [Man] Hey.
- Hey!
- How's it going?
- [Woman] Good!
Glad you could make it!
- Yeah, yeah, thanks for having me.
(phone ringtone)
(text tone)
- Yes!
- [Man] No.
- I'm gonna grab some ketchup.
- Don't pick up, don't
pick up, don't pick up,
don't pick up, don't pick up.
- [Voiceover] Hey, this is my voicemail.
(woman sighing of relief)
Leave a message.
(car door opening)
- You Shane?
- [Shane] Uh, yep!
- Mind if I turn the radio on?
- Uh, please!
(Shane sighing of relief)
- Yes!
(crowd talking simultaneously)
- Oh, Shane?
Did you have something you wanted to say?
- Oh.
Yeah, I got an idea.
- [Woman] Oh, let's hear it.
(woman heavily sighing)
- My God, you guys, I
just had the worst day.
I just really need someone
to unload all my problems on.
And my boyfriend called me
and he's like, it's
not feeling it anymore.
And we had this whole hour
and a half long conversation
and I need to tell you every
single word that was exchanged.
I just need someone to listen.